الوضع يعني كلمه كارثه هي كلمه قليله على
وصف هذا الوضع المنطقه في شمال غربي سوريا
هي منطقه تعتبر منكوبه بالكامل لم يمر على
هذه المنطقه ولا على سوريا بالعموم يعني
مثل هذا الزلزال لم يستجب فرق الخوازل
البيضاء يعني منذ التاسيس هذه المنظمه منذ
بدايه الثوره السوريه عام 2011 لم يعني
يمر عمليه انقاذ على القوات البيضاء بهذا
الحجم وبهذا المستوى حتى الان الفرق منذ
اللحظات الاولى من وقوع هذا الزلزال
متواجد للفرق العمل الدفاع المدني يعني
اعلن حاله الاستنفار الكامل الكامل الاطقم
وكامل الاليات ووجه هذه الاليات الى اماكن
العمل اللي من اجل تقديم المساعده
للعالقين تحت الانقاض ولكن هذه الجهود
للاسف هي جهود تحتاج الى تضافر دولي كامل
حتى نستطيع ان نخفف يعني من من
هذه الكارثه على هؤلاء السكان وعلى هؤلاء
العالميين تحت الان